One of the mantras we have heard
ad nauseum since the beginning
of the COVID situation has been
that we need to follow the
science. This phrase is repeated
over and over by politicians, by
experts and by celebrities.
"Let's end the politics and
follow the science." This phrase
must be expressed with a certain
level of condescension, implying
strongly that your ideological
or political enemy is not
following the science. And if
they did follow the science,
then they would naturally agree
with your political position.
"Will people listen to
scientists?" We've heard certain
political parties smugly even
call themselves the "party of
science". Now, we could argue
all day long over who is
actually following the science
and people do, pointing fingers
at each other, and going down
the dreadful line of clickbait
headlines citing some new study
which suggests how their
position is the one following
the science. But to do that is
already to miss the forest for
the trees, because it is
actually simply, and dare I say
technically, impossible to
simply follow the science.
The question is far more
important than just surrounding
the current COVID situation.
It's rather the sign of the
general blind materialism which
rules the common discourse.
We're wowed by the scientific
priestly caste. We only need to
look at the type of reverence
the media placed around Dr.
Fauci in the United States. But
like I said, despite our
officials constantly repeating
this mantra, it is impossible to
just follow science, at least
not at the outset.
When science is doing what it's
supposed to, it's an accurate
and quantifiable description of
phenomena at a certain level of
reality. And so because
phenomena happen in a
predictable pattern, then once
you've described a phenomenon
accurately enough, it can be
possible to produce the same
phenomena with similar
conditions. So think of the
scientific process as producing
something like a recipe book.
Once you've identified something
relevant, let's say making a
pound cake, then the recipe book
will tell you what stuff the
cake is made of. So if you
follow a set process using
similar quantities, you know,
what certain raw materials,
eggs, flour, etc, and a certain
amount of time, then you should
be able to reliably produce the
phenomena which will be
recognised, which will have the
recognised qualities of a pound
cake. So notice I said if you
follow a set process, which of
course seems to suggest that you
can, in fact, follow science,
but this is exactly where lies
the problem and the blind spot
which has become so common. You
can only follow the science once
you have identified what it is
you care about, what it is you
want to do, and especially what
is your hierarchy of priorities
within a certain context.
Science cannot tell you what is important.
So let's say you decide you want
to kill as many people as
efficiently as possible, well,
then you can follow the science
to find the best procedure and
tools to do so. If you want to
reproduce a nuclear explosion,
make people addicted to your
product, create an army of
robots, then science can
possibly help provide a map to
accomplish these measurable
goals. But science has no tools
whatsoever for telling you what
you should do, what goals you
should be aiming for. And
science also cannot tell you
what is the reasonable amount of
resources you should spend on a
certain goal, or what else you
need to sacrifice to accomplish
your goal. So let's say you want
to make your pound cake. But you
can only get eggs by driving two
hours from your house. Well,
science has no way of telling
you if that is a reasonable
thing to do. Or if you want that
pound cake enough to sacrifice
that time and energy to still
make it, maybe you do. And this
blindness has been the source of
one of the biggest political
clashes since the end of World
War Two.
Following the science has
provided the means of material
excess of comfort and throwaway
culture and now other branches
of science, environmental
science, is telling us to follow
the science to save the
environment from the results of
this other branch of science who
develop their industrial thrust
by following the science. And so
science is a tool and neither of
these opposing narratives,
neither the reason for the
development of industrial
civilization, or the reason for
the green reduction of energy
consumptions are scientific in
themselves. Both paths, both
mentalities, follow the science,
but they do so to their desired
goal. So this whole question has
reached almost absurd levels
with the COVID situation. We're
constantly told to follow the
science, that, you know, this or
that political decision or
mandate is not in fact political
but is mandated by science. At
best, this is the naive
proposition of people who are
unaware of their own frame,
unaware of what motivates their
action, but at worst, it is a
new form of moralising which
wants to pretend that its moral
stances are as self-evident and
as provable as two plus two
equals four. The goal is
sometimes stated. At first, we
had a goal, we were told that we
needed to prevent the medical
system from being overwhelmed.
But then the goalpost moved
invisibly to, "We need to stop
our people from dying at all
costs." And finally, the
goalpost became, "We need to
stop this disease from being
spread to anybody at all."
So despite moving the goalposts,
authorities continued to use
this same message, "Follow the
science," while pretending that
the goal is continually obvious.
It is just taken for granted and
is just plainly there in the
science itself. Of course, if
you have followed my channel,
you have bumped into this
problem over and over. It's the
problem that I had in my
discussion with Brett Weinstein,
where science was posited at the
top of the hierarchy of meaning.
It's the blind spot in my
discussion with Rationality
Rules, where moral arguments
were made as if their ultimate
purpose were evident, while
simultaneously being incapable
of framing, of naming or even
seeing that purpose before
invoking this or that example or
this or that consequence. All of
these conversations are in a
different way than we usually
mean it. They are blinded by
science, honestly thinking their
objective, though blind to their
presuppositions. Thinking
they're objective and
scientific, they take their
unseen presuppositions as self
evident truths, which people,
which all good people or people
who have good intention, should
be able to see. And so those of
us who question this or that
moral position can find
ourselves in dangerous
situations. Because if one takes
their point of view as
self-evident, this inevitably
means that those who do not
share this perspective are doing
so out of ill will, or with
purposeful and utilitarian
denial of science. That's why we
always hear a note of contempt.
Every time a political figure or
public figure says, "Follow the
science" or when they suggest
that their political opponents
refuse to follow the science.
Accusing someone of not
following science is akin to
accusing them of breaking a
divine command. Science is of
course objective,
non-ideological, and so to not
follow science is to go against
reality itself. It's a sin,
properly speaking, for those who
think like this.
Of course, all the while the
inquisitor is hiding or maybe
even unaware of the true purpose
of his actions. That is why I
say there is imminent danger
right now. As for the reality of
safety versus danger, of saving
lives versus providing
opportunity, normal societies
have always had to find ways to
balance these extremes. It's not
easy, of course. But this is an
inevitable discussion that we
should be able to have without
those who want to have the
discussion being accused of
being "science deniers" or being
insensitive and evil. If the
goal of human society was only
to save lives, we would not go
rafting or mountain climbing or
even get on the highway. We know
that intuitively. But despite
that, we're suddenly paralysed
by this strange illusion that
safety and protecting our bodies
is the only value that matters.
Of course, it would be absurd to
say that it does not matter. Of
course it matters, we should
care for the physical wellness
of those around us. But it
cannot be our only guiding
value. Safety cannot be
accomplished at the expense of
every other value which
constitute the human experience.
Value like community exchange,
adventure, risk taking and
especially worship. Every time
you get into a car, you risk
your life. And every moment you
are in a car you could die in a
few seconds. And this is in no
way under your control. You're
are also at the mercy of other
drivers. In the United States,
for example, the rate of death
for car is about 12.4 per
10,000. But there are also 4
million people who are seriously
injured by car crashes. Road
crashes are in fact the leading
cause of death in people between
1 and 54 years old. Now, we
could reduce the death and
injury rate of car crashes very
easily. We could simply stop all
private cars from going on the
road. Done. Or we could reduce
the speed on the highway at 20
miles per hour. I mean, I bet
that would bring down the car
death toll and injury took
nearly zero. It would work but
we're not going to do it. So why
aren't we going to do it? I
mean, why wouldn't we do it? Am
I saying that getting to my hair
appointment or to some, you
know, to go to the mall is more
important than people dying?
So we intuitively understand
that in order to live our lives
we incur risks of dying. Of
course, car crashes and
infectious diseases are not the
same. And we certainly need to
care for the weak and the
elderly. But my point is rather
to feature our willingness to
accept the constant risk of
dying at any second every day.
And intuitively knowing that
safety cannot become the only
value which drives our society.
And we must be very wary of
those who refuse to even have
the discussion, insisting that
the very discussion is immoral,
because it doesn't "follow the
science." We have to be more
aware of what a human being is,
and not let that go to the side
in a society that is built only
on one single value, a value of
safety or security. A human
person is more complex has other
values, other purposes and some
are actually more important than
our safety.
I hope enjoyed this discussion
on Symbolic World. As you might
have noticed, I am in a new
space. I am back in my home
since the flood in 2019. But you
can also notice that I am not
yet set up. I'm really
struggling to set up my office;
the stores are all closed, we're
on lockdown and the stores are
also out of everything. I can't
even find a desk the right size
for the office. And so I'm kind
of floating around trying to get
everything installed and trying
to get everything right. But
very soon, things will be
better, you notice the camera is
better, the sound will also be
better, the lighting will be
better. And so I'm really
excited to see what 2020 one's
going to offer us in terms of
insanity. And hopefully I'll be
able to comment on it as best I
can. And so I want to thank
everybody for your support. As
you know, everything I'm doing
here is thanks to your support.
And so if you're interested in
supporting the podcast, these
videos, go to
thesymbolicworld.com/support,
you will find ways to support it
there. You can also buy some of
my designs, different designs
that I've made on Teespring. And
so thanks everybody and I'll
talk to you very soon.